[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultants editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kevin mcguire with us from now until
just before midnight oh andrew you're
very short we can fix that i'm sure
we'll we'll elevate his chair
there we go anyway front pages while he
does that um ahead of tomorrow's
elections the guardian reports that some
tory candidates are seeking to distance
themselves from boris johnson by
branding themselves local conservatives
the daily mail carries an attack by
boris johnson on what he calls liberal
left lawyers trying to block his plan to
send asylum seekers to rwanda
the ft leads with the latest moves by
the u.s federal reserve but also
features the disagreements between
certain eu countries over how to handle
a ban on russian oil which has been
proposed
as it did last night the telegraph
leading with calls for an inquiry into
the use of french exocet missiles during
the falklands war
and the metro hears that the shirt in
which diego maradona won the 1986 world
cup quarterfinal for argentina by
scoring a goal against england with a
handball has sold for
7.1 million pounds
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us we'll hope to bring the other
papers in they're all hanging out for
the champions league no doubt uh but
andrew and kevin are here with us now um
so to the elections we go we can't talk
about it after midnight it's about to
make hay now um a bit of expectation
management being brought in by both
sides i think about this don't you
andrew but what should we be looking out
for
well it's always difficult anna um and
good evening because um turnout is very
low um uh
about five thousand seats are being
fought the tories have told us um
the tourists say that if anything above
800 is going to be a bad night but some
people tell me they'll probably lose
near a 400. uh labor will probably what
labour want the big thing for labour is
to come second in scotland replacing the
tories they've been second for quite a
while behind the snp but they want some
of those big big prizes like wandsworth
westminster which have been stubbornly
tory even in bad years for the tours
even when theresa may was very unpopular
ian duncan smith was unpopular they held
on to those sort of constituencies but
so some of those big flagship boroughs
will be the prize for labor uh i think
they'll do well labour in london because
it's increasingly a less and less
conservative city and as the opinion
says on its front page a lot of councils
councils the tories are pitching it as
the local tory they've been doing that
actually since 2019 actually that's when
it was first registered by conservative
centre office because theresa may was so
unpopular she lost by the way 1400 seats
in the local elections uh in 2019 and
she was gone weeks later if boris
johnson who's 1400 seats i think he'll
be gone too but i still don't think the
local elections will be what decide
boris johnson's fate i think that will
be other factors the cost of living sue
grey's report when that comes out uh and
uh other other facts
okay kevin hold your thought i know
you're itching to come in just a bit of
breaking news and uh sad news certainly
for fans of manchester city out of the
champions league not through to the
final against real madrid six five uh
losing on aggregate uh certainly uh that
means it will be a liverpool versus real
madrid final on the 28th of may in paris
uh all hoping for an all england final
of course not to be
uh with the spanish team beating
manchester city six five anyway sad news
um i know you're a football fan i'm
looking at kevin not not
not andrew but um
but uh yes i know i mean a very
stressful stressful game for everybody
to watch certainly
it's fantastic for real madrid who just
don't know when they're beaten but how
manchester city can snatch defeat from
the jaws of victory you get the 90
minutes and you're going through and you
throw it away
you have to lose in the final last year
i mean it's it's a disaster for them but
you know if you're a football fan in in
britain uh probably apart from some
parts of manchester and maybe everton
now you can bat liverpool quite happily
well i will because sunderland never
compete
at this level though i don't feel any
rivalry if it was new castle enough to
think otherwise yes exactly one day one
day um but let's head to the guardian
and return to our conversation about uh
the elections taking place tomorrow and
this idea of whether johnson is now a
hindrance to the conservative party you
know the great heineken politician who
could touch parts of the electorate that
nobody could and and this sort of
suggests that it might be backfiring
according to this guardian article
yeah he's gone from as you say the
heineken uh politician who could uh
touch places others couldn't to almost
kryptonite for the tories uh which is
why they're distancing uh locally
themselves from him i think he's on very
few conservative party leaflets he's on
a lot of labour and liberal demographic
and possibly uh snp and plied and green
too because he has he's lost he's lost
his mojo he looks a a haunted and
hounded uh man and andrew's right i
don't think these local elections
whatever happens uh tomorrow and we get
the results friday uh what won't do for
him but i'm told lucy wakefield could
and certainly if um tiverton and
hummington were the concerns of 24 000
majority that's bigger than the seats
they lost in north shropshire and uh
cheshire and amisham if that fell um to
the lib dems who are the most likely
challenges or finished the last time
behind labour but that if that falls
then i think johnson would fall with it
yeah it is is
is a no confidence vote looming for
johnson that's what the metro asks in
its inside pages um and also the
environment say george eustis being
branded out of touch and patronizing
after telling shoppers to beat the cost
of living crisis by switching to value
brands i suppose the point is making
that um every cut you make helps you out
but uh still the the out of touch issue
andrew is you know it's it's a really
tricky one for the government if if
people think the government can't help
them in any way which is what it feels
like to people
look you know um i just it's so
patronizing when politicians cabinet
ministers earning 160 000 pounds a year
and have a
chauffeur-driven car tell shoppers mums
but not often mums or
dads who are struggling with the
shopping bill get by a cheaper brand
when they wouldn't know a cheaper brand
if they fell over one in a supermarket
aisle it's just really really crass and
stupid look the cost living crisis is
the big big problem facing this country
forget partygate many people are
genuinely struggling to pay their fuel
bills people are worrying about food
bills uh they're wearing even more
because we have a cold winter coming up
this year we know the price caps going
to be lifted again
and i think the government needs to do
more
and soon on the cost of living crisis i
think it's insane to put up national
insurance i know the money is allegedly
to cut the nhs waiting list well we'll
see if that ever happens because often
big infusions of cash to the nhs just
disappear into a black hole so um those
sort of remarks by uh george eustis uh
are frankly really insulting to voters
and have families and when you've been
in power for 12 years that sort of
remark does suggest to people that they
are a bit out of touch he's a good bloke
george you says you know if you talk to
him one to one and i'm sure he's kicking
himself for saying it but the fact is he
did say it yes and the actions of the
european union today this proposal to
ban uh russian oil imports obviously
being fought by a number of nations
hungry slovakia you know finding it
tricky certainly um but the but already
four percent rising crude oil prices on
the day or immediately afterwards you
know the pressure will keep coming if
you start cutting off the avenues that
you get this stuff kevin
it is it's a it's a price of um
supporting ukraine and taking a a
principal position against russia after
the unprovoked uh invasion you will pay
you'll pay an economic price i suspect
that down the line there's going to be
some very cheap deals for russian gas
and oil if european customers are not
not taking it but
the pressure is going to get worse the
financial times leading on the fed in
the u.s putting up interest a half
percent they're going to go up again
in the uk as the bank tries to curb
inflation but it will
really sting people if they haven't to
pay more on their mortgages they have to
pay more in shops and their wages aren't
going up as high and the government is
taking more in taxation it's i
understood what george eustis was saying
and i'll have a little sympathy for him
but people are making those choices
themselves they don't want a minister
and a government which has made it worse
not better to be lecturing them i recall
edwina curry when she was a minister
back in the 80s when thatcher was prime
minister
when people are struggling with their
bills well she said well if it's cold um
put on another jumper well yeah in one
way it was it was a bit of reasonable
advice but people don't want to be
forced to do it and told to do it by
by a minister they they want the
ministers the government uh to help them
not to be lecturing them
you had a little smile at the mention of
thatcher there andrew i have to say as
soon as you went through it
no no no no
i was just thinking about wiener curry i
think she also said wear a woolly hat in
bed
there we go because she said you lose a
lot of heat through she said you lose a
lot of heat through your head so wear a
woolly hat
in bed and some people it divided the
nation was she giving sensible advice
yes but was it patronizing uh yeah
probably did um
did john major wear a woolly hat in bed
do we ever know that
i've i've never been privy to his
bedroom secrets but if you read edwina
curry's book i'm sure he may disclose it
i think we found out something about his
underwear and it was big green baggy not
very oh they were blue they were big and
blue big and blue very tory yeah let's
stop shall we here anyway let's go to
the daily mail andrew your paper you
might as well do this one question did
the rwanda plan stop the movement of
migrants across channel the answer it
seems is no and it was the weather so
what is boris johnson complaining about
in in this front page
well already apparently the legal
challenges are flying in thick and fast
of course they are from the great human
rights uh crusading lawyers that kevin
mcguire loves so much
they will try and they will try and tie
this plan up in league or not doing
everything they can to even if people
are they try to deport them to rwanda
they'll be lawyers appealing and
counter-appealing uh and and this was
always going to be a battle
and i think actually it's a battle the
government wants because they'll point
to the labour party which has got no
plan other than to say everybody can
come in anybody they like can come in we
won't send anybody back and they and
they'll fight the lawyers and they'll
say they'll try to say to people we at
least are trying to do something to stop
this appalling falling uh convoy of uh
misery coming across the english channel
okay kevin yeah
carl where do you where do you start one
that is not labour's position just let
anybody yes it is
two you talk about a convoy of misery
over coming over the channel what do you
think you're gonna be sending to
rwanda
three the reason uh people uh on going
to rwanda and the government pretty
patel and johnson said it would start
this month is they haven't got their
scheme in place yet and fourth
or fourthly we live in a country of the
rule of law people have rights
uh it's not just little mini dictators
telling them what what must happen you
have a right and the government has to
comply with its own laws and there will
be challenges and legal challenges and
they've got to be heard we need we need
a system that works that's effective and
efficient we don't have one but we live
in a country of the rule of law
that's labour's policy
is this ludicrous
squeeze in another story if that's okay
gentlemen um which is uh that it makes a
change to daily mail not only don't
beergate andrew to be fair um and the
daily telegraph uh quoting uh sir peter
farhi former head of greater manchester
blue suggesting that durham constabulary
should you know possibly think about
looking again at the case in light of
new information but i mean has there's
been politicking by the daily mail do
you think ahead of the elections
woken up to this story and uh are
reporting the fact that kiev starmak is
refusing to answer very basic questions
he's been evasive he's what he's doing
he's doing what he's accusing boris
johnson on for a very long time he's
been lying about what happened in in
durham in that durham labor constituency
office that night everybody can see
through it with the sun reported this
week 200 pounds worth of curry was
delivered for 30 guests the story has
changed from kirsten he's come from
saying we were working we had a break
from work we had some food and then we
went back to work he's now saying we
were working continuously you know when
politicians change their story anna
they're on very thin eyes
durham police looked at this uh last
spring and decided no rules were broken
because at the time you could reasonably
have a meal at work when you were
involved in business and this was
campaigning what happened with johnson
is the met police didn't look at it at
the time and then when they did look at
it they find him and found he broke the
law the tories are trying to muddy the
water and the male are playing along
with the game that's what it is
right you can see the policies in it
okay we will we will we will move we
will move on uh would you pay seven
million pounds for the shirt that
maradona used to cheat
his way to the world cup well someone
did we will discuss that in just a
moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me once again andrew
pearson kevin mcguire welcome back to
both of you um day two for the daily
telegraph on the exact falklands uh
story andrew um tell us a bit more about
uh their persistence with this well this
started in charles moore's excellent
column in the telegraph he's a former
editor of the telegraph the official
biographer of margaret thatcher so he he
reminded uh
readers a story that i think was
probably in his memoirs but when the
minister of defense uh when we went to
war with argentina the minister defense
suspected that there was a device by
which you could disable the exorcist
which was the argent titanium's most
lethal weapon it took out hms sheffield
of course with 40th anniversary this
week 20 servicemen died they've got a
former commander of the hms chef was
saying the french have questions to
answer but look this was 40 years ago
are the french really going to get into
a conversation about that now i'm not
sure and what i think is really
interesting about the 40th anniversary
of the falklands hannah is there is to
be a big service where
service men and women who died
particularly people like those who run
the sheffield will be remembered i think
it's at the arboretum you think prince
andrew will be there big public role
place for him because of course he
played an heroic
role in the fall clinton
decoy helicopters to try and divert um
argentine planes from from british ships
and a final minute from for you
apologies for rushing you the metro the
hand of ward the hand of god uh it's the
front page of the times as well which is
uh just in one of those papers obviously
waiting for the uh for the football but
anyway an interesting amount of money
for uh for this incident which is goes
down in footballing history for for
england um kevin
absolutely seven million hundred and
forty two thousand five hundred pounds
for the uh the the cheats shirt uh back
in 1986 so he used his hand to get the
ball over uh peter schulten it was owned
by a steve hodge who was in the team
and i think he i think he owns it so
he'd get the money uh i had been on loan
at a museum the football museum in uh in
england but it looks like the uh some
people from abu dhabi have
bought it but what that's a hell of a
lot of money for uh what do they want
what do they want it for
they'll display it i suppose get people
to go to abu dhabi on a holiday
it's a moment of history isn't it let's
be honest with you but at the time
it's a cheap shirt it's a cheats shirt
he cheated yeah well there we are it's a
moment of history still but anyway the
time is just very quickly leading on
inflation expected to rise to the
highest for 13 years and the paper
saying the bank of england is forecast
to raise interest rates uh from 0.75 to
1
we will talk about that in our 11
o'clock bulletin when we see you again
thank you both very much indeed